[Music]  what is it you like to talk about  my patient  hi  i know you're nervous i just want to  have a chat  i'm seeing something no one else can see  except for me  it's smiling at me  [Music]  yesterday a patient in your care died  brutally in front of you  [Music]  i need to find an explanation for what  happened  it's smiling at me  it's smiling at me  [Music]  [Music]  i found 20 cases involving 19 victims of  the direct line linking them all  together  [Music]  why is it that everybody else who's seen  it is dead and you're alive  i've seen it too  you  [Music]  how long between each victim's death  none of them survived longer than a week  today is my fourth day  i am not gonna keep  running i have to face it  how does it make you feel  [Music]  i'm just really scared that something  bad is going to happen  [Applause]  [Music]  you